après les condamnations de l'offensive
russe en ukraine plusieurs pays
occidentaux comme la france et les états
unis passent aux sanctions économiques
contre la russie nous avons coupé la
plus grande banque de russie d'une
banque qui détient à elle seule plus
d'un tiers des actifs bancaires de la
région l'avons coupée du système
financier américain ce stade de son côté
le conseil européen qui réunit les
dirigeants de l'union européenne vient
d'approuver des sanctions financières
sans précédent contre le kremlin dans
son viseur le secteur de la finance de
l'énergie et des transports
ce package de sanctions incluent des
sanctions financières sur l'axé juste 10
importants marchés de capitaux mais nous
ciblons 70% du marché bancaire us mais
aussi des entreprises publiques majeures
qui comprennent les secteurs de la
défense ces sanctions augmenteront le
taux d'emprunt de la russie
l'inflation est heureux devront
graduellement la base industrielle route
le président français emmanuel macron a
par ailleurs annoncé que la france
allait apporter son soutien financier à
l'ukraine une aide économique sans
précédent à l'ukraine a été acté
avec l'adoption d'un paquet des de macro
financière de 1,2 milliard d'euros
elle ira plus loin il continuera à
mobiliser tous les moyens financiers
matériels je vais essayer dire que la
france contribuera à cet effort
supplémentaire avec 300 millions d'euros
pour l'économie ukrainienne et nous
sommes prêts à continuer à livrer des
matériels militaires et de soutien à la
population comme j'ai pu le dire au
président et disques le conseil de
sécurité de l'onu est appelé à voter une
résolution condamnant la russie mais le
pays qui occupe actuellement la
présidence tournante utilisera-t-il son
droit de veto l'otan de son côté
organisera un sommet virtuel aujourd'hui
pour décider des prochaines mesures
l'alliance atlantique est en état d'
alerte depuis l'offensive en ukraine